hi everyone
my name is philip i am a machine
learning engineer at hugging phase and
the tech lead for our partnership with
aws
i will show you in a few minutes how you
can deploy hiking fast transformers from
s3 to amazon sagemaker for an influence
amazon sagemaker is a fully managed
machine learning service that provides
everyone with the ability to build
train and deploy machine learning models
quickly together with aws we have
built an inference optimized solution to
deploy transformer models as
sagemaker endpoints let's get started
we are going to use a sagemaker notebook
instance to deploy our model
using a sagemaker notebook instance is
not a requirement to deploy a model you
can also use
sagemaker studio or you can deploy it
from your local machine
to be able to deploy a model from s3 to
amazon sagemaker you need to create an
archive called model.tar.gc
which contains all the relevant model
and tokenizer files
if you have trained your model before
using the amazon sagemaker and the
hugging fest dlc
for training this archive will be
created automatically for you at the end
of your training and uploaded to sv so
if you have already drained the model
you can
use this model for deployment in this
case i will use a distal bird model
fine-tuned on the sst-2 dataset
to deploy our model we first need to
create a hugging fast model
class the hungry phase model class
contains all the relevant information
for our endpoint
as our model data where the model
archive is stored
on s3 a role for the permissions our
transformers version and the python
or tensorflow version the eigenphase
inference solution is
can be used with pytorch or tensorflow
after we created our hanging first model
class we can run
dot deploy the dot deploy method will
then create our sagemaker endpoint
therefore we
define the initial instance count and
the instance type the initial
instance count defines how many
instances will be used for our endpoint
and the instance type defines which
instance will be used
in our example i use the m5 instance
which is a cpu based instance
after executing this sagemaker will
create our endpoint which takes around 5
minutes
the endpoint has been successfully
deployed to sagemaker and can now be
used for inference
the benefit of using the python
sagemaker sdk is that the dot deploy
method automatically returns predictor
class which we can use to request our
endpoint
therefore we can run predictor.predict
and
provide our inputs as an input i have a
yeah a simple
sentence phrase
executing predictor.predict
our endpoint successfully predicts the
correct class
for our input and works
at the end you can run predictor delete
endpoint which
makes sure everything will be deleted on
sagemaker
properly if you want to learn more about
the hugging face on amazon stagemaker
check out huggingfest.com